[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans une nuit noire de 1990 ge a été
arraché à mater pas deux inconnus pour
une destination méconnue
j'ai atterri dans un endroit où tout le
monde était de peau blanche et parler
une langue qui mettait étrangères
quelques jours plus tard je me suis
retrouvé dans un endroit où hommes et
femmes portaient des blouses blanches
ces personnes là ne faisais que mob
sculpter le poser des questions principe
mille fois j'ai eu à poser des questions
en 20 ans c'est mille fois j'ai eu envie
de mon fuir sans savoir comment y
parvenir
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis
manuel a été handicapé moteur
j'ai subi 36 intervention chirurgicale
en italie et j'ai même été trois fois
dans le coma
vous savez à chaque malheur il ya
quelque chose de positif qui en ressort
nous étions 200 enfants en situation de
handicap au centre de nos riantes de
benoist il fallait en choisir qu'un seul
ou se fait soigner en italie et j'ai été
choisi
j'avais 4 j'ai été arraché à mater et je
me suis retrouvé dans un lit d'hôpital
et là ma vie a vraiment basculé
je voulais dit plus tôt à chaque malheur
il ya quelque chose de positif qui en
ressort
dans cette chambre j'ai fait la
connaissance d'un jeune garçon de 13 ans
qui s'appellait dario ce jeune garçon
m'a prise pour sympathie et ainsi que
toute sa famille ainsi cette famille là
s'est battu pour moi ils se sont dit
mais comment se fait il que cette petite
fille de quatre ans qui parle même pas
bien l'italien qui parle sa langue
maternelle là se retrouvent comme ça en
italie tout seul ils se sont battus pour
moi ils m'ont donné la chance de pouvoir
étudier de pouvoir rêver m'amuser comme
tout autre enfant
et là c'était la joie de vivre
malgré les difficultés malgré la douleur
de l'hôpital malgré les soins cinq
années se sont écoulées et là j'ai dû
revenir en afrique
leur taux en afrique vous savez la
tendance en afrique c'est la
stigmatisation des personnes en
situation de handicap
moi je ne le savais pas avant de
continuer j'aimerais vous poser une
question que pensez vous de la personne
en situation de handicap
avez vous une idée que pensez vous de
cette personne là y'a aucune réponse je
vous comprends pas ce que l'handicap
c'est ce qui fait un peu peur l'handicap
c'est l'inconnu
l'handicap c'est la stigmatisation
l'handicap c'est long c'est pas beau ça
fait peur on sait pas quoi y faire
et moi je veux que cela je vais vous
faire un tableau
à ma droite la flèche de la vie à ma
gauche la flèche de la mort on ne s'en
rend pas compte mais il ya beaucoup de
familles africaines et même dans le
monde qui tendent la flèche de la mort
peut-être que ça va vous sembler un peu
vise à ce que je dis mais je vais en
faire un exemple
imaginez vous une famille de cinq
personnes papa moment trois enfants le
petit dernier qui assure muet et cette
famille là reçoit des invités des
invités de prestige et la maman dit pas
puni ce soit je te dis c'est vraiment la
chose de bach paponi aujourd'hui tu ne
sont pas tues le reste dans ta chambre
bb je ne veux pas sa chronique un moment
reste là tu as entendu et pas puni comme
ça reste dans son coin
imaginez vous un peu c'est enfin là
qu'il ne peut pas parler ne peut pas
enfin pour parce que cet enfant doit
rester seule pendant que ses autres
frères ils peuvent découvrir le monde
ils peuvent se faire voir un autre
exemple une soirée où une journée entre
amis
et vous invitez vos amis vous leur dites
on m'invitait à un gala de mode tout ça
j'aimerais y aller
qui aimerait bien venir avec moi et il
ya une qui soudain ça mais jacqueline
oui oui moi j'aimerais venir vous lui
dites jacqueline partons j'ai pas envie
d'être insultés ou avec de gros sel qu'à
me suivre d'un espoirs de mougins crime
ces peuples et un reste tranquille et
elle vous dit pourquoi
on va y aller même avec mon cousin quoi
celui là avec cette grosse dieu là il
faut penser qu'on a lu mais de grosses
touches en pleine journée
ils seront bien choquer pourquoi parce
que jacqueline et son épouse et n'ont
pas cherché à voir ce que vous notez
comme différence et pour parce que moi
ma nuit là et pas pour nous nous devions
expliquer aux gens que on est en
situation de handicap
ça m'a été donné comment est ce que je
vais faire pour expliquer que oui moi je
suis différente
oui je suis voilà mon pied comme ça et
toi non mais non c'est parce que moi
manu l'âge existe et naomi campbell
c'est qu'elle a de jolies jambes n'est
ce pas aa c'est ainsi mais moins manier
là je peux lui dire tu sais dieu m'a
doté d'une grasse que tu ne peux pas
savoir le moins j'arrive à me faire un
peintre par ce don là et c'est comme ça
je me suis dit ayant vécu dans l'est
deux continents ayant connu plein de
personnes qu'est ce que je veux de ma
vie non je veux pas être stigmatisé non
non non non non je veux pas être dans ma
petite cabane là et n'est pas pouvoir
évoluer je parle une autre langue
je parle le français je parle l'italien
j'ai étudié j'ai un don n'est pas parce
que je bats rester là et accepter qu'on
me dise manu là tu n'as pas le droit de
toi quel droit à tue plus que moi je
suis une personne comme toi ma
différence est un atout
la différence
et moins à tous
donc je vous dis aujourd'hui c'est mon
combat
j'ai décidé de mettre sur pied une
association pour lutter pour ce faisant
ces enfants là pour lutter pour que tout
le monde puisse comprendre que la
différence est une richesse
j'ai pu être maire c'est une grâce on en
a quatre
je suis en train de tout faire pour
ouvrir mon âge mon nom mon entreprise de
consulting
c'est une autre bénédiction l'ovalie et
jamais le purent être la lauréate de
deux grands concours en concours
ivoirien est un concours panafricain et
ça je priais dieu tous les jours pour
cela je vous dis moi je rêve d'un monde
où il y aura des amendes à payer pour
les moqueries
je rêve d'un monde où nous allons
échanger travail est enceint que la
différence de chacun puisse devenir une
force pour l'autre je rêve d'un monde où
nous allons exposer nos enfants à ce que
la différence est une richesse
avant de terminer j'aimerais vous poser
la même question du double que pense
vous maintenant de la personne en
situation de handicap
je vous remercie
cette chanson je la dédie à tout le
monde parce qu'on peut donner la chance
aux enfants de se réaliser
lp soir
et là surprise on
fois c'est une trace de dieu
perso
le fils d'adam lind louis chant d'amour
de pureté pipeau c'est tout seul
m
[Musique]
un don
demain
q
j ai peur qu il en soit le captur est
enfin venu
autrement dit
ce que l'on appelait
youpi
dupuis
un stand alone ou dans les bois
ça
o est parfait et pâques ce site
elle risque américains
brad pitt famille de kate ses coûts et
my diverti victor noblet
des états unis
[Musique]
aurait pas
jamais
m
avant
non
thomas
là
avant
à
il est au dessus
et auxerre et tous devront
non
bah
[Musique]
jetons mena ton rythme des chants de
marins de piloter prix porte c'est tout
ça
ce
oh non mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont
[Musique]
cela
à mes yeux
/
[Musique]
est parfait et peaux exotiques à
lisbonne
la famille 4 go
n'a pas pas
étape 1
je me
[Musique]
non
en
[Musique]
ban
il sait
et tu devrais
non
au mans
mychele daniau
show l'année
[Musique]
là
les dieux du rhône ans
[Musique]
il ya six ans
merci
l'asie
[Applaudissements]